[Music]
morning everybody it is seven o'clock
thank you for watching us from singapore
to iceland this morning lots in the
prime minister's inbox he's on the
offensive trying to stop a war in
ukraine but at home on the defensive
with fresh pressure over parties and ppe
this morning
big news too as the government's
levelling up paper is revealed the
leveling up secretary michael gove on
the show as is the shadow levelling up
secretary lisa nandy what does that even
mean we'll be asking it's wednesday the
2nd of february
i'm live in wolverhampton which is
getting a share of funding aimed at
breathing new life into areas outside of
the south east but critics say there are
no new ideas and no new money
ppe parties and putin the three p's on
the prime minister's mind with fresh
revelations this morning
i'm here in kiev as vladimir putin and
boris johnson trade diplomatic barbs and
as the president of this country warns
of a fully fledged european war
a resignation and a loss of sponsorship
the fallout after a scottish football
club signed a player a civil court ruled
is a rapist
weaponizing our grief jimmy savelle's
victims call on boris johnson to
withdraw his commons comment to secure
stammer referencing the sex offender the
labour leader gave us his reaction
yesterday on the probe it is a
ridiculous slur peddled by right-wing
trolls
kids in hazmat suits our beijing
correspondent investigates china's covid
preparations as the clock ticks down to
the winter olympics
also on this morning's breakfast program
for you food for thought we'll examine
what the cost of living crisis means for
you and your kitchen cupboard
[Music]
this morning ladies and gentlemen i'm
singing and reading that at the same
time bob marley is in the news but why
[Music]
stay tuned and we'll tell you meantime
three p's on the prime minister's mind
today putin parties and ppe but another
p making news at home that's their new
policy announcement on levelling up to
spend more money outside of the south
east
plenty to talk to the levelling up
secretary michael gove about shortly
first let's take a look at the leveling
up white paper it runs to 400 pages and
sets out a strategy to spread
opportunity across the country by 2030.
it includes a promise to increase
investment in research and development
outside the southeast by at least 40
percent
baths and rail services will be improved
to bring them closer to standards in
london
and more areas will get access to 5g
broadband there are also pledges to
improve maths and literacy rates in the
worst performing primary schools and
there could be a shakeup of local
government with more powers devolved
over issues like transport and elected
county mayors money is also being made
available to regenerate 20 town and city
centres starting with sheffield and
wolverhampton
lisa standing by for us in wolverhampton
this morning one of those areas that
should receive quite a lot of money
she's with us now tell us more lisa good
morning
morning this former brewery site is
already starting to be transformed here
in the city it's home to a school and
university but around about there is
plenty of disused areas which need
regeneration and the leveling up money
is going towards creating more than a
thousand new homes on the derelict parts
of the site and they're going to create
what's called sustainable walkable and
beautiful neighborhood for people
ministers are saying there's also
millions more going to be spent on the
city and they're also going to have the
leveling up headquarters based here and
they're recruiting for civil servants to
staff that so wolverhampton and
sheffield are the first of 20 areas to
get a share of this 1.5 billion pounds
of leveling up cash
but what labour is saying is that the
money isn't new it was already announced
a lot lisa thank you
the man in charge of all of that is the
leveling up secretary michael gove he's
with us now good morning hi good morning
joining us on the program uh is any of
this money new well i think that's a
bogus argument because the chancellor
gave us a huge check in the spending
review and now we are spending it and
we're making sure in wolverhampton in
sheffield and in other areas that we put
our money where our mouth is and that we
make sure that money which in the past
was spent too much in london and the
southeast is now spent in the north and
midlands where it's needed okay although
of course there are quite a few areas in
london i'm thinking tower headlights
just down the road that need quite a lot
of money themselves well there's
inequality in london and you're
absolutely right tower hamlets barking
and dagenham
they need support as well and the
government is working with the mayor of
london in order to do that but one of
the the big problems that we have as a
country is the geographical inequality
uh london and the southeast uh an
economic powerhouse but the north and
midlands not so much and that's why we
need to invest in schools in skills
that's why we need to improve wages
that's why we need to make sure that we
level up across the country people
who've been forgotten
forgotten by whom overlooked and
undervalued for years by him well by
politicians the brexit referendum was a
wake-up call
as well as a a clear commandment to
leave the european union it was also a
way of saying to people in sw1 people
like me look
it's vital that you change the economic
model of this country it's all very well
if people are in london and the
southeast and financial services and
others do well we don't begrudge that
but you've got to listen to us and in
2019 the baton was passed to boris there
was a clear instruction deliver for us
we've had two difficult covert years but
now that we're coming out of it we are
making good on that promise by a
commitment to improve jobs and wages by
spending more of the science money that
is so vital to growth in the north and
midlands and also by making sure that
the schools and colleges that people
attend are fit for purpose okay but you
guys have been in power for the majority
of this century
well there have been mistakes made by
parties of both colors and one of the
things in the past is there have been
sincere and uh committed attempts by
politicians left and right to deal with
this but nothing as comprehensive or as
long term as the plan that we're setting
out today yeah okay but you do
acknowledge that you guys have been in
power for 12 years yes i do and one of
the things about that is that you've
forgotten these people up and down the
country well as i say there was a
wake-up call in 2016 and one of the
things that is often um you know one
charge that is often made against uh
governments is that they run out of
steam i think what we're seeing here is
a commitment to make sure that far from
running out of steam we're firing up
every engine of the economy i think it's
also important to recognize that when
boris was elected prime minister there
was a new government with a new mission
and that mission was to level up and
we're giving the detail today on how we
do that and very soon after he took
power of course he had to deal with a
global pandemic absolutely and to that
end uh you had to spend uh 12.1 billion
pounds on ppe but 8.7 billion of that
apparently was wasted
not quite
was that panic buying what was it no not
quite firstly i'm not going to apologize
for the fact that we moved heaven and
earth to get all the ppe that people on
the front line needed now some of those
figures are uh uh
accountancy markdowns the relationship
seven billion no yes some of it is
because some of the accountants are
using well the key thing here is that uh
the uh the price that we paid for ppe at
the height of the pandemic is greater
than the cost now and that is because
everyone was in a global race to find
that a lot of it was rubbish and you
couldn't use it no um more than 97
percent of it was absolutely right with
the [ __ ] excited about those planes
that were coming into raf bryce norton
that we were sending film crews up there
the stuff was coming in from i think i'm
right saying turkey
turkey saudi arabia china hong kong
globally no the overwhelming majority 97
was used and sorry it was usable was fit
for purpose on the front line i remember
right at the beginning of the pandemic
my friend the shadow
chancellor rachel reeves labour mp
writing to me saying please please
please get ppe and she gave us a list of
people that we should contact including
people who were you know uh uh uh
theatrical medieval costumes
and uh that was on that plane was not
usable at that point everyone was
screaming at us get more ppe and we got
it and that was the right thing to do at
that time um and those figures are uh i
think uh erroneous and inflated and more
importantly a bit like we made for the
ppe no well at the time okay everyone
was desperate to get ppe there were
doctors in germany outside the german
parliament
complaining
well it was no case to answer at all uh
no i'm proud of what we did okay okay
well let's see what happens as far as
that's concerned have a have your tea
while i ask you uh because you'll need
it when i ask you about what's happening
as far as jimmy savile and that comment
that the prime minister uh made uh on
monday i think this is what he said just
to remind our viewers
this this leader of the opposition a
former director of public prosecutions
mr speaker he spent most of his time
prosecuting journalists and failing to
prosecute jimmy savile as far as i can
make out mrs speaker
as you can imagine kia stammer not at
all happy about that he was on the show
yesterday actually this is what he said
it is a ridiculous slur peddled by
right-wing trolls
uh he's doubled down today the prime
minister it seems in the sun saying that
he doesn't want to apologize do you
think he's got anything to apologize for
no okay lindsey hoyle thinks he has
lindsey hoyle said i'm far from
satisfied about the comments and lawyers
for the several victims have accused
your leader of weaponizing their
suffering you still don't think he's got
anything to apologize for no i think
this is a uniquely sensitive issue and
it does need to be handled with care and
i listen with enormous respect to those
who uh act for uh victims of um
you know the actions of a terrible
terrible uh criminal but um and it's not
a subject that i want to dwell on
because it is uniquely sensitive it is
the case that the uh the cps apologized
for the handling of this case and what
happened in 2009 um and i think we
should acknowledge that an apology was
given at the time and respect that uh he
wasn't directly involved in the uh
zakiya stamina when he was head of the
dpp at the time or he was the dpp at the
time and he says it was it's a slur well
i i i respect pierre's point of view but
i think it is also the case that it's
it's on the record and indeed he himself
acknowledged that errors were made he to
his credit brought in uh a very
distinguished lawyer alison levitt to
look at the situation and then an
apology was made i think we should
respect that so lindsay hoyle um is
wrong as uh are the lawyers for the
sample victory no i'm i'm not saying
that i'm i'm saying that uh uh
in a uniquely sensitive case
kierstama acknowledged that mistakes had
been made by the organization of which
he was head to his credit uh he was very
clear about those mistakes he brought in
an independent lawyer to look at that
and i think that we should recognize
that in doing that he did the right
thing okay let's move on to parties um
should we i'm sure that story will
continue on but thank you for your uh
answers for now party's um
investigations two more parties uh were
being told about uh in the newspapers
today
apparently one of them showing that the
prime minister was there's a photograph
of him we haven't seen it yet we're told
that it is available or will be of him
at the party the flat in his own um
in his own flat in above number 11
always get mixed up between number 10
and number 11 because he's number 10 but
the flats above number 11 is it's a
little bit bigger let's remember what he
said on the 8th of december
i can understand
how infuriating it must be to think that
the people who have been setting the
rules have not been following the rules
mr speaker because i was also furious to
see that clip
i have been repeatedly assured since
these allegations emerged
that there was no party
and that
and that no
kovid rules were broken
he was building our upper heads
well
all of these allegations are being
investigated by the metropolitan police
um there's been
any number of allegations in the
newspapers but again we've just been
talking about the importance of
due process and law and i think it's
only right that we allow the match to
get on with their work and then
appropriate conclusions can be drawn at
the end of it he must have known if he
was in his own flat with lots of people
singing abba hits the winner takes it
all well
we'll as i know
uh have all sorts of allegations and
speculation in the media fair enough but
the met are doing their job and until
they've concluded i don't think it would
be right for me to comment
come on he knows whether he was in the
flat or not singing abba hits well i i
all i would say is that i wasn't in uh
no but he was well
there are all sorts of allegations that
have been made i know that some of the
allegations that have been made and i
don't want to get into that but i know
some of the allegations that have been
made um in some parts of the media are
speculation that is not true and so
therefore i can't uh act as an automatic
okay let me put it this way all of them
i've called them and i'm not asking each
other the met are looking at this
if he was in the flat singing the winner
takes it all with his misses when he
said that he didn't know about any
parties he misled parliament should he
resign
uh i
uh again you're asking a hypothetical
question i think i think during the
pandemic why is that hypothetical well
during pandemic i think there were some
moments when um i may have been sitting
at home and working listening to music
and concentrating um on
my job while at the same time were you
eating birthday cake um
no but the
the whole point of
was somebody singing happy birthday to
you well the whole point of uh the met
investigation is that uh
you don't have to ask and i don't have
to ask uh uh officers can ask um and
they can make sure that they establish
all the information and once they've
concluded their their investigation
then we can know we are
it would appear a laughingstock he he is
straddling the world stage and trying to
be very statesmanlike and we've been
looking at some of the quotes this
morning russia and tv reaction if it
were within the power of boris johnson
the report would have been vanished into
the bowels of the victorian sewers of
the city of london and this one from the
washington post the circus uh must uh be
what the circus music for give me is
winding down for bojo the clown we're a
laughingstock no i think that when
you're uh quoting from uh russian
television the washington post they've
got on to the washington post
let's go with that one then if you don't
like the other one are you going to
cherry pick i thought we couldn't cherry
pick oh i don't know
i'll look at both of them okay first of
all one of the reasons why russian
television is attacking the prime
minister is the prime minister is
leading the west's efforts okay in order
to ensure
in order it's important to deal with
both of them in in order to ensure that
we defend ukraine's territorial
integrity against putin so of course
he's going to be attacked by russia um
and a single commentator in uh
admittedly respectable but still
center-left american newspaper oh okay
it's not it's not it's not
representative of world opinion let's
try this one but i'll tell you what is
happening internationally and that is um
in the ukraine there is a recognition
that britain and poland are its two
strongest allies we were told after
brexit britain would be on the margins
on the sidelines of the big
international issues but the prime
minister was welcomed by president
zielinski um and vitaliy klitschko in
the in ukraine yesterday okay because
our commitment to provide uh uh
assistance to the ukraine shows that we
are standing tall for democracy far from
being
criticized by uh democrats uh
internationally we are leading the fight
for democracy and eyewear is a badge of
pride the fact that russian television
is attacking our prime minister okay um
what about sir malcolm riflin how do you
feel about him former foreign secretary
old friend of mine he says it damages
the authority of the british government
yesterday he was due to speak to
president putin and was forced to cancel
that very important conversation because
of his domestic difficulties back home
talking about him having to appear in
the house to talk about sue gray as
opposed to speaking to putin
uh i think vladimir putin got the
message when uh the prime minister was
in the ukraine yesterday we've given the
ukraine the weapons it needs to protect
itself we're going to take the sanctions
against russia necessary if there is a
single russian boot that crosses the
border there and so uh i don't think you
necessarily need to uh dial uh vladimir
putin on his mobile phone for him to get
the message that he should back off okay
good to talk to you thank you very much
for joining us thank you i know you'll
come back and talk to us as soon as
we've got the report from the met
absolutely there you go the guardian
leads with labour's criticism of the
government's leveling up white paper
saying michael gove has failed to
squeeze extra funds out of the treasury
for the plans we just heard what mr gove
had to say about that uh the metro
reports on an investigation which
discovered a culture of racism misogyny
and homophobia in the met police
the time splashes with energy bill
rebates which are hoped will help with
rising costs the mirror warns households
could be out of pocket by 2 000 pounds a
year due to the cost of living crisis
the eye splashes with tories put pm on
notice claiming the tory party's
patience with the prime minister is
running thin the express is attacking
the conservative government for writing
off an 8.7 billion pound loss on
protective equipment bought during the
pandemic
mr gove having none of that either
the daily mail points out that including
fraudulently obtained covered loans that
figure is actually 13 billion pounds the
telegraph claims that hormone
replacement therapy will soon be sold
over the counter the sun reports on the
manchester united footballer mason
greenwood who has been arrested for the
second time in recent days
and don't forget at 9am next monday the
7th of february the education secretary
nadim sahari will be here to answer all
of your questions you can send them to
us via twitter or email uh you can send
it to ask the education secretary at sky
dot uk
still to come this hour though what does
labour make of the government's leveling
up white paper we'll be speaking to the
shadow leveling up secretary lisa nandy
in the next hour top of the next hour
plus we'll be speaking to the mayor of
the west midlands andy street to find
out if government funding is helping
level up his constituency
with boris johnson deep in crisis talks
for the tensions between ukraine and
russia speaking to the former ambassador
of ukraine to the eu
the prime minister boris johnson is to
speak with russian president vladimir
putin today about the situation on the
ukrainian border he's been in kiev
speaking about the situation with his
ukrainian
ukraine and russia this will be a
full-scale war in europe
a further
russian
invasion
of ukraine
would be a political disaster a
humanitarian disaster
in my view would also be
for russia
for the world
a military disaster as well
adam's joining us from kiev um hi adam
how did it go these talks
yeah i think the the focus switched a
little bit from
the earlier position of both of these
leaders because mr zalenski ups at this
point had actually been
referring to uh to
see that massive buildup of troops on
the border and telling ukrainians to
calm down not to worry
that the government could deal with it
and yet here he was talking about the
potential for what he described there as
a fully fledged european war
and boris johnson i think a bit of a
change of attack from what we've heard a
lot about the the rhetoric from western
leaders about the power of economic
sanctions
about trying to effectively dial down
the threat of war well he here was boris
johnson talking about exactly that and
talking raising the specter of of
russian mothers worrying about their
sons going to war both of these people i
think projecting this image of a
potentially bloody
long
complicated protracted
military conflict that could drag in not
just ukraine but much of eastern europe
this didn't feel to me like two people
who were trying to dial down
the tension and it also came against the
backdrop of
vladimir putin who was welcoming victor
orban the hungarian leader uh and mr
putin has really said that this is all
down to nato expansion that the
americans are trying to whip up a
problem
and his argument is look if nato is
expanding into
uh well much of eastern europe if
ukraine were to sign up to nato
then what does russia do about this area
of crimea which it says is part of
russia if it sends troops in there then
that could precipitate a a world war now
of course boris johnson would say well
this is all just propaganda that the
build of a hundred thousand troops
unprecedented number of troops on the
border is completely uh inexcusable what
i think we didn't get yesterday was any
real opportunity to to puncture
that tension which means that the
rhetoric has been ratcheted up it
certainly did put mr johnson central on
the world stage but was he here as a
peacemaker
no not really
and thank you live from kiev looking at
today's other headlines for you now
manchester united footballer mason
greenwood remains in custard this
morning after he was further arrested on
suspicion of sexual assault and threats
to kill
the 20 year old had already spent two
nights in jail when greater manchester
police were granted more time to
question him he's been suspended from
playing or training with his club for
further until further notice following
his arrest on sunday
shoppers have been hit by the highest
price rises in almost 10 years according
to the british retail consortium
according to the trade association shop
inflation has almost doubled in the last
month with families increasingly
struggling to deal with the rising cost
of living
and in the next hour i'll be speaking to
gemma godfrey from the time money mentor
to find out what we can do to cope with
the rising costs of living
[Music]
this is just some of the footage from a
new documentary celebrating the
achievements of north korea's leader kim
jong-un the almost two-hour film titled
the great year of victory 2021 was
broadcast on the country's state-run
television channel
the common crane is making a strong
comeback in the uk after becoming
extinct here in the 17th century wild
birds returned in 1979 and a survey
found a record 72 pairs with a
population
now estimated at more than 200
and the duchess of cambridge has taken
over from prince harry as patron of the
rugby football league and the rugby
football union kate starts her new role
ahead of the guinness six nations
tournament this weekend where she'll be
in direct competition with her husband
who himself is patron of the welsh rugby
union
now it sounded like a money-making
scheme that dell boy trotter himself
would probably come up with here we go
it's the queen's platinum jubilee
it got an only fools and horses twist
not just talking about the image that
they're using there of the queen i don't
recognize her
the chinese manufacturer produced
thousands of souvenirs in her honor but
like many ideas devised by peckham's
finest there's always a missing detail
that scuppers the deal can you see it
all 10
800 teacups mugs and plates mistakenly
have platinum jubbly
rather than jubilee printed on them
that has certainly tickled jerry our
camera operator this morning they're now
being sold online to both fans of the
queen and the famous series
uh scotland's first minister nicholas
sturgeon has entered the row over
scottish championship side wraith rovers
and its decision to sign a player who
was said to be a civil court by a civil
court judge to be a rapist she backed
best-selling author and lifelong rover's
fan val mcdermott who has ended her
support for the club and cancelled her
shirt sponsorship
let's find out more with ashna in the
newsroom hi ashna tell us more about
this story yeah the five football club
is coming under some mounting pressure
because of this new signing of a new
signing of a new striker called david
goodwilly now he has been signed on a
two-year deal but it's not his football
talent which is drawing criticism more
so his background back in 2017 he was
ruled to be a racist in a civil court
case he never faced a criminal trial at
the time over this rape accusation
prosecutors said that there wasn't
enough evidence but he was ordered to
pay the victim a large sum of money but
fast forward to today and he assigned to
this football club but loads of people
are criticizing him including val
mcdermott who is a successful crime
writer over in scotland she is the club
sponsor too and she's distancing herself
from him saying i've cancelled next
season's shirt sponsorship over this
disgusting and despicable move she says
this shatters any claim to be a
community or family club joining her in
cutting ties k is the women's side
captain tyler ratway she says after 10
long years playing for wraith it's
gutting i have given up now because they
have signed someone like this and i want
nothing to do with it it was good being
captain of wraith while it lasted the
football club however have defended
their decision they say david is a
proven goalscorer while acknowledging
the gravity of what happened 10 years
ago they go on to say as a club we fully
support and encourage rehabilitation and
many factors influenced our signing but
the last sentence of the statement reads
first and foremost this was a football
related decision this hasn't stopped
though a number of people resigning from
the club including two directors and
joining the condemnation as the first
minister of scotland nicolas sturgeon
okay thank you
in other news for you a new bob marley
exhibition is coming to london but don't
worry about a thing everything's gonna
be all right we couldn't chat about his
music though and without hearing a
little bit
[Music]
you were doing this weren't you at home
while you were having your toast this
new exhibition takes a look at the
star's musical legacy but also his
significance as a political figure the
exhibit will feature multimedia
memorabilia which has never been seen
before
okay here's a bit more
[Music]
i prefer the other one don't you
apparently laura likes that one i'm not
sure that's why it's there anyway she's
the boss with a career spanning almost
20 years marley was considered to be one
of the pioneers of reggae music he also
ranks as one of the best selling music
artists of all time
how many records do you think he sold
75 million the exhibition at london's
saatchi gallery opens today
uh looking at this
happy landings let's have a look
doesn't seem to apply have a quick
listen is he easy easy
oh my god
[Applause]
yeah i can still hear bob marley as well
here's the terrifying moment a plane was
forced to abort its landing at heathrow
airport when faced with strong winds
from storm corey almost down almost down
almost
down i had to go around
the british airways jet arriving from
aberdeen yesterday morning initially
touched down before breaking sharply to
the left and beginning its go around
procedure the pilot successfully managed
to land the plane on the second attempt
of course he did because he's one of
ba's finest or it could have been she
quick look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
next few days will be mild with some
rain around at times but friday looks
briefly colder most places having a mild
and cloudy start to the day with patchy
light rain mainly confined to the north
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
a world record has been broken for the
single longest bolt of lightning let's
have a quick look
i'm not quite sure what i'm looking at
but wow this image shows the single
flash of lightning in the sky covering
three states in the us the lightning
bolt extended
477 miles across texas louisiana and
mississippi
i'll take their word for it still to
come this hour speaking to the mayor of
the west midlands andy street about what
the government's leveling up plan means
for his constituency stated
[Music]
good morning again everybody our top
stories for you so far this morning the
government unveils its long-awaited
plans to level up the gap between richer
and poorer parts of the uk saying it
will shift power and money to the north
boris johnson dodges questions relating
to newspaper reports claiming he
attended two more lock down breaking
parties being investigated by the met
and he's going to be speaking to the
russian president today about the
ukraine crisis but one of moscow's top
diplomats has told sky news that british
diplomacy is making the situation worse
throughps on the prime minister's mind
today putin ppe and more downing street
parties
newspaper reports this morning suggests
that boris johnson did attend a party in
his flat on the 13th of november when
abba was played after dominic cummings
left his downing street role i asked the
levelling up secretary michael gove
about the allegations
there are all sorts of allegations that
have been made i know that some of the
allegations that have been made and i
don't want to get into that but i know
some of the allegations that have been
made um in some parts of the media are
speculation that is not true and so
therefore i can't uh act as an automatic
okay let me put it this way all of them
and i'm not asking each other
if he was in the flat singing the winner
takes it all with his misses when he
said that he didn't know about any
parties he misled parliament should he
resign
uh i
again you're asking a hypothetical
question i think i think during the
pandemic why is that hypothetical well
during pandemic i think there were some
moments when um i may have been sitting
at home and working listening to music
and concentrating um on
my job while at the same time were you
eating birthday cake um
no but the
the whole point of
was somebody singing happy birthday to
you well the whole point of uh the met
investigation is that uh
you don't have to ask and i don't have
to ask
officers can ask and they can make sure
that they establish all the information
and once they've concluded their
investigation
then we can know
i'm back at what he said in more detail
with tamara's take at nine o'clock but
he also talked about ppe he also talked
um about jimmy savile that is really
developing into quite a row isn't it and
leveling up that's right um on the
parties there's a couple of new
revelations today um first of all in the
telegraph which claims that this party
on the 13th of november the one where we
saw dominic cummings earlier in the day
leaving downing street with his box he
his time there was finished allegedly
carrie johnson the prime minister's wife
hosted a party in their number 10 flat
with abba songs blaring out the
telegraph claiming today that the prime
minister was present for that late night
gathering i have to say okay that's the
one that a lot of tory mps are really
concerned about because that's not work
that's a social event in a house then
you've also got in the guardian today
claims of
in sue grey's report there was one
gathering she mentioned that we didn't
previously know about in january of last
year of 21 so that sort of the dark days
of the winter lockdown they're saying
that that was actually a leaving do for
a senior civil servant and they say that
boris johnson attended that one two so
that's another one that the pm is being
placed at the center of so this very
much not going away and then on top of
that yes you've got this row over jimmy
savile um the prime minister saying on
monday that
hitting out at kierstama saying um he
failed to prosecute jimmy savile when he
was director of public prosecutions
something that people who were there say
is not true he would have known nothing
about and now having members of his
cabinet double down on it okay tomorrow
for now thanks very much tomorrow's take
nine o'clock very much looking forward
to it thank you see you again at the top
of the eight as well meantime the
government is to publish its
long-awaited leveling up plan to narrow
the gap between richer and poorer parts
of the uk but what will this actually
look like for communities the mayor of
the west midlands andy street is with us
now hi mr street thank you for joining
us on the programme what will it mean to
you
yes good morning 2k to be honest with
you so what it means to the citizens
here rather more important than to me is
of course better opportunities better
outcomes in life so whether that's
better transport connections better
schools better skills in their colleges
or ultimately better jobs through a more
vibrant private sector all the things
that have been talking about ultimately
come together to deliver that
how quickly they
oh something's already happening if you
take the transport piece we've already
been agreed a billion pounds of new cash
with the government already just at the
end of last year if you take what's
going on in brownfield remediation
regenerating communities in derelict old
industrial spaces that's happening now
but some of the things are a much longer
burn i accept that take all the work
that's talked about about research and
development getting more money spent
here less concentration on london in the
southeast that takes time but in time
that will definitely drive new
businesses in new sectors to locate here
in the west midlands
yeah but a lot of people will need to
see
a bit of action weren't they ahead of
the next election
yeah i don't question that and that's
why i say some things are already
happening actually so if you travel
across the west midlands you will see
you'll see railway stations tram
extensions already happening you will
see derelict industrial sites coming
back to life you'll see new colleges
being built like the new wonderful
institute technology in dudley that is
there to see now but actually what the
white paper does today is say how can we
move beyond what you might call a
patchwork of what we've done already to
something much much more complete that
drives the private sector economic
recovery in these regions how much
longer does this prime minister have in
office
that's up to him to demonstrate the
answer to that question uh it all
depends on what actions he now takes
frankly he's given an apology a fulsome
apology but my own view is he now has to
follow through on that and show that he
genuinely genuinely means it and
genuinely change will occur and if that
occurs then the answer to your question
will be in the hands of the british
electorate um what what if he broke the
law would you still do you still does he
still have your 100 support if he breaks
the law of course as i've said before
they will uh there is the police
investigation don't actually know yet if
the prime minister personally is being
investigated by the police but if so
there'll obviously be consequences as is
with any other citizen
what about if he misled parliament
well i'm not a parliamentarian but i do
know this just from seeing the the rules
very clearly that the prime minister
must know
that that would be a very very serious
uh uh uh allegation and i'm sure that
he's been very very careful in what he
said to parliament because he
understands the gravity of that
and you believe him when he says that he
didn't attend any parties
uh i actually i can't know the answer to
that can i about this event on the 13th
of november i think the one that you're
talking about i suppose you can in that
you can say sorry to interrupt but in
that you can say i trust the prime
minister so if he tells me this i
believe him
and my honest answer that question is
yes i do believe that uh i believe that
this that what you see from a man in a
very difficult situation this week and
no one is condoning it what happened was
bad was wrong frankly from where i sit
was pretty unbelievable and i share the
feeling of most of my constituents that
this is just inexplicable but i do see
someone who is genuinely remorseful is
understanding the lessons that have to
be drawn and i like to believe that i
can trust my prime minister
just to clarify what what do you think
was unbelievable sorry
did it actually happen that um and and
that the events that during the sue grey
report were as described because we all
lived under very different arrangements
i mean my role is tiny compared to the
prime ministers i understand that but
doing a public role like this you do
have to think about what's appropriate
what you should do what you shouldn't do
we cancel lots of things so that's why i
say it's unbelievable that it's happened
but that's now a matter of public record
from sue gray and what we've heard from
the prime minister is his reaction to it
and what we've now got to see is how he
follows through on that
but from reading what sue gray has said
he broke the rules didn't he
he it would appear that uh he broke that
the rules around uh lockdowns uh
uh were broken yes and he's given a
fulsome apology for that but you asked
me about two other specifics one about
what the police were going to
investigate which we don't know the
outcome of yet and b you asked me about
uh the uh what he said to parliament
which again we don't know the outcome of
yet
no okay well i think okay okay i'm sure
you'll come back and talk to us um when
we do but but nevertheless i wonder what
the people in your community
are thinking about the politicians down
here in london at the moment do they
still um do they still support the prime
minister and the government where you
are at the moment well i think actually
it's very interesting that question
because it relates the first half of the
interview about leveling up to this
actually what people here say is um
uh there's a it is it has led to
distrust of politicians in london
absolutely no question probably
politicians across the piece but
actually what people say to me is what
you've got to do as our local leader is
get on and deliver proof that voting
conservative in the mayoral election and
actually in the general election is
going to deliver those better life
chances that we are going to get those
things we're talking about and that is
my singular mission and honestly i think
today the moves that michael gove is
putting in place will help us do that
it's always great to talk to you mr
street thank you for sparing us the time
thank you very much thank you very much
thanks a lot opening ceremony for the
beijing winter olympics takes place this
friday and covered preparations are in
full swing here's tom
this was always going to be a different
winter olympics one where nearly all the
snow is artificial where there are no
tickets on sale for spectators and one
which has been boycotted by western
governments
it's also one in the middle of a covid19
surge in china districts across beijing
are conducting mass testing and knocking
down neighbourhoods
and there have been lockdowns across the
country
officials have been typically zealous in
their pursuit of what's called a dynamic
zero coveted policy sometimes fighting
covid with literal fire
or sending dozens of young children to
quarantine
as a result the olympics are being held
in the closed loop system keeping
athletes and anyone else coming for the
games and potentially bringing kovid
isolated from the rest of the country
this was one of the athletes villages
before the loop closed
uh
and so it's fortress olympia officials
have even told beijing residents not to
help olympic vehicles involved in
traffic accidents for fear of breaking
the loop
it's a pretty formidable barrier what
they've done is create a city within a
city actually a country within a country
because over that barrier is effectively
international territory carved out of
the heart of beijing
an ordinary members of the public cannot
buy tickets to events only those
selected by the chinese communist party
can attend
despite all that locals are still
excited and proud that their city will
be the first to host the summer and
winter olympics
it is a tense moment in beijing if not a
panicked one
authorities will be relieved if they can
focus on the sport instead of kovid tom
cheshire sky news beijing
the winter olympics torch relay has
started in beijing as the fortress-like
city prepares to host the global
sporting event despite boycotts by world
leaders and covert 19.
this morning the torch set off and will
be carried by more than one thousand
torch bearers by the various competition
areas in beijing and the nearby city of
zhang zhu
before the opening ceremony on friday
evening
soldiers and villagers on ukraine's
eastern front have told sky news that
they're seeing more activity from
pro-russian separatists there
our chief correspondent stuart ramsey
reports from the luhansk region
the last kilometer or so to the
front-line trenches of this conflict in
eastern ukraine is always by foot
the separatists positions are never far
away
the trenches that now stretch hundreds
of miles in higgledy-piggledy length are
defensive
but essentially they're an overwatch
system to keep an eye on the movement of
the russian-backed separatists and more
importantly any incursion by the russian
army and there's been more activity
at night particularly yeah we're
surrounded conditions here are miserable
and dangerous
the troop commander explained our
position essentially in the middle of
the separatists
i understood
the soldiers say in recent weeks has
been more activity and more firing from
the separatist side
the snowy hillock and towers are their
opponents lines it really isn't far at
all
it is easy to forget that this conflict
has been going on since 2014
the scars of the fighting are everywhere
abandoned and destroyed buildings litter
the landscape
the villages and towns on the front line
aren't always deserted but they're very
quiet now and few people venture outside
if they can avoid it well these towns in
eastern ukraine are very remote but they
were very very busy those things have
changed now because
they are actually the front line
when you see things like this as your
houses that took
direct hits by grab rockets from the
separatist side it's easy to understand
why most people have decided to get out
of town the only ones who have stayed
behind now are really those who can't
get out and have got nowhere to go
while the diplomatic moves and prime
ministerial meetings take place both in
ukraine and abroad the fact is that the
two sides are stuck
battle lines drawn
and to them there's nothing to suggest
things will change
there is a real sense that this freezing
front line is frozen waiting for some
sort of breakthrough that could relieve
the tension
that or another round of bloodshed
stuart ramsey sky news eastern ukraine
well joined now by the former ambassador
of ukraine to the eu and that's
costiante and yelisiev thank you very
much indeed for joining us on the
programme this morning what did you make
of the meeting yesterday between our
leader boris johnson and
the leader of the ukraine
yes good morning first of all we
appreciate very much
that prime minister johnson paid the
visit
to ukraine to the important uh period
so
a few
very important period of history for the
whole europe because currently the
question of war and peace in europe is
now being decided exactly in ukraine
and ukraine is the last puzzle in
putin's uh geopolitical gate
in order to revive your soviet union
that is why
this visit of prime minister of
the uk was very
tired
and we appreciate very much what the uk
is currently doing in order to help
ukraine to strengthen ukraine's
resilience by providing uh
defensive lethal weapons now what we do
expect from the uk and from
the uh
unity is to introduction of uh
preventive sanctions against russia
because russia invaded ukraine back in
2014
and violated all
of international order on which
post-cold
world was based so that is
why we
turn a solidarity with ukraine of the
whole international community and we
count very much on
unprecedented transatlantic unity
because this is what putin is afraid of
we have one or two um challenges uh mr
ambassador with our communication with
ukraine this morning but we will
persevere for now if you'll indulge us
well the prime minister said a russian
invasion would be a political and
humanitarian disaster in his words um
how do we avoid that eventuality
i guess uh or how we can avoid uh my my
uh appeal uh to everybody to not be
afraid to surprise putin uh putin is
afraid of uh transatlantic unity
which is a big prerequisite for
sanctions
the question
russia will weaken russian potential uh
to
go with the war
against ukraine
we we need to uh provide to us to get
help from the international community
namely to strengthen security and
military and defensive potential of
ukraine by providing uh weaponry thirdly
uh we need to stop uh north stream too
this is guy's gas pipeline system which
was built by russia uh uh by passing
ukrainian territory to germany
and uh of course what we need also this
is uh the security guarantees and the
best securities guarantees is ukraine's
membership in nato this is what putin is
afraid about in my view providing
ukraine with a membership action plan
with nato would be a biggest uh blow for
putin and biggest sanctions against
putin so this is uh
the key prerequisite
the key factors which which will uh
uh provide us with a victory and of
course another very important point do
not be uh do not uh do
not to make any concessions for putin
because if ukraine failed
the whole
community will fail so ukraine currently
is ready to fight against russian
aggression now what do we do back again
real solidarity of the whole world with
ukraine
mr ambassador thank you for taking the
time to join us on the breakfast show on
sky news this morning thank you
quick look at the weather for you
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
next few days will be mild with some
rain around at times but friday looks
briefly colder
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
some of the more eye-catching stories
from this morning's papers for you here
we go
lots of us will love the aroma of
scented candles but how much are you
willing to pay they're expensive aren't
they well this one on sale in selfridges
has been getting choppers on their
nerves certainly coming at a whopping
600 pounds those with money to burn can
get their hands on the collaboration
between parisian brands troodon and
balmain there you go
600 quid for that one
what else have we got for you today we
can go to the mail as well he's been
painting it black with the rolling
stones for nearly half a century and now
the guitarist turned amateur artist
ronnie wood maybe about receiving royal
recognition for his portraits uh there
you go
and uh one more for you i think as well
maybe
um there you go that is a dolphin at the
side of a huge huge huge boat or is it a
ship i never know somebody will be upset
about it uh still to come on the
programme for you this morning uh a
healthy dose of eating salad we'll be
telling you about this this rabbit
is taking on this human eating salad i
mean what else is that to say frankly
i love it i love it yeah the rabbit
doesn't like it he needs a bit more
dressing on it doesn't he um coming up
in the next hour we're going to be
telling you what the government minister
has been saying to us today and also
hearing from lisa and mandy that to come
in just a second
[Music]